telecinco j'espère que vous allez bien
et aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour
décrypter le programme d'eric zemmour en
dix mesures alors si vous avez vu
d'autres décryptage déjà sorti sur cette
chaîne vous commencez à connaître le
principe l'idée c'est de détail et dix
mesures fortes d'eric zemmour pour vous
donner un bon aperçu de son programme et
de sa vision de la france sachant que
comme pour tous les autres candidats ça
vient en complément de son interview qui
va sortir sur cette même chaîne youtube
dans les prochains jours du coup nous
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner jeu mais ce
n'est pas encore le cas pour ne pas
louper les interviews et les décryptages
de tous les candidats
alors avant de commencer petit point sur
le parcours de ce candidat eric zemmour
est né en seine-saint-denis il est issu
d'une famille d'origine juive algérienne
de nationalité française arrivé en
france métropolitaine en 1952 et eghezée
moore se définit lui même comme un
français d'origine berbère et eghezée
moore a été pendant longtemps
journaliste notamment au journal le
figaro il a écrit de nombreux livres
certains ont créé une vive polémique
comme le premier sexe ou encore le
suicide français il a aussi été
chroniqueur à la télévision sur france 2
notamment mais aussi sur i télé qui est
devenu ensuite la chaîne ces news 20
novembre 2021 il a officialisé donc sa
candidature à la présidentielle alors
qu'il n'avait jamais c'était candidats à
une autre élection il a fondé quelques
jours plus tard son parti politique qui
l'a nommé reconquête enfin sur
l'échiquier politique
eric zemmour est considéré comme un
candidat d'extrême droite mais lui
refuse cette qualification voilà après
cette rapide présentation passons
désormais aux dix grandes mesures d'eric
zemmour première mesure et c'est sans
aucun doute la mesure la plus connue
d'eric zemmour le candidat souhaite
réduire l'immigration à presque zéro
pour stopper en fait ce qu'il appelle le
grand remplacement le remplacement
supposée de la population européenne
paru nos populations immigrées pour
stopper ça eric zemmour va donc réduire
le nombre de gens autorisés à entrer en
france il souhaite mettre fin au
regroupement familial c'est à dire donc
la possibilité pour les étrangers avec
un titre de séjour d'être rejoint par
les membres de leur famille eric zemmour
veut aussi limiter le droit d'asile à
quelques dizaines ou centaines de
personnes par an et enfin il souhaite
sélectionner avec plus d exigence les
étudiants étrangers qui viennent en
france en accueillant que les meilleurs
étudiants étrangers pour favoriser je
cite le rayonnement de la france
deuxième mesure eric zemmour souhaite
réduire certains droits des étrangers
comme le droit du sol qui fait que
aujourd'hui un enfant né en france de
parents étrangers peut obtenir la
nationalité française sous certaines
conditions concernant les aides
financières aussi eric zemmour souhaite
supprimer toutes les aides sociales qui
sont non contributives donc les
allocations familiales les aides au
logement ou encore le rsa le minimum
vieillesse il souhaite supprimer toutes
ces aides là aux étrangers qui ne sont
pas originaires d'europe il veut
également supprimer l'aide médicale
d'état qui permet aujourd'hui aux
étrangers d'avoir des soins de santé
gratuits cette aide est aujourd'hui
attribué sous certaines conditions à
noter là dessus que marine le pen est
aussi favorable à cette suppression
troisième mesure eric zemmour souhaite
expulser tous les étrangers qui jugent
indésirable selon lui concrètement c'est
tous les étrangers sans emploi depuis
six mois ou encore tous les étrangers
arrivés clandestinement en france j'ai
aussi expulser tous les délinquants et
criminels étrangers avec dès son arrivée
au pouvoir une expulsion immédiate
de plus de 10000 délinquants étrangers
ils sont actuellement emprisonnés en
france enfin il souhaite retirer la
nationalité française à tous les
criminels et délinquants
multirécidivistes qui ont une double
nationalité
et puis ensuite après cette déchéance de
nationalité il souhaite les expulsés du
territoire français sur ces sujets là
aussi avec zemmour est très proche de
marine le pen à cela près que marine le
pen propose d'expulser les étrangers
après un an sans travail contre 6 mois
pour eric zemmour quatrième mesure elles
concernent la justice eric zemmour veut
qu'elle soit plus ferme pour les mineurs
et donc il propose d'abaisser la
majorité pénale de 18 à 16 ans ce que ça
veut dire c'est qu'avec une majorité
pénale à 16 ans et bien un jeune qui à
16 ou 17 ans sera jugé comme un adulte
et donc avec des peines forcément plus
lourde qu aujourd'hui est par ailleurs
autre point si eric zemmour est
président et bien les parents de mineurs
délinquants ou criminels ne recevront
plus aucune aide financière de l'état
cinquième grande mesure cette fois ci
c'est une mesure économique eric zemmour
souhaite réduire les impôts sur la
production et les importations donc
globalement faire en sorte que les
entreprises aient moins d'impôts au
quotidien il existe différents types
d'impôts sur la production mais eric
zemmour n'a pas précisé lesquelles
exactement il souhaite diminuer même si
selon lui est bien la réduction totale
pour les entreprises sera de l'ordre de
30 milliards d'euros autre mesure
d'ailleurs concernant les entreprises
eric zemmour soit supprimé les droits de
succession et de donation
donc ces droits là c'est en fait l'impôt
payé lors de la transmission des
entreprises familiales l'idée derrière
cette mesure c'est d'encourager les
français à transmettre leur entreprise à
leurs enfants en effet selon eric
zemmour avec le système de taxation
actuelle est bien les entrepreneurs sont
plutôt encouragé à les laisser dans les
mains d'investisseurs étrangers
6e mesure qui concerne cette fois ci le
pouvoir d'achat eric zemmour souhaite
augmenter le salaire net des
travailleurs modestes pour ça il compte
supprimer la contribution sociale
généralisée pour ceux qui gagnent moins
de 2000 euros nets par mois et ce alors
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde doit payer
cet impôt cette mesure permettra par
exemple un travailleur qui au salaire
minimum et qui gagne donc actuellement
près de 1200 sont 9 euros par mois de
gagnés à peu près 100 euros de plus par
mois en est et pour financer cette
mesure eric zemmour comptent supprimer
pour les étrangers les aides sociales
qu'on évoquait à l'instant donc rsa
allocations familiales encore
allocations logement et c'est donc cet
argent qui permettra d'augmenter le
salaire minimum des français ce que
propose eric zemmour c'est donc une
forme d'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat
mais pas une augmentation directe du
montant des salaires comme la plupart
des candidats à gauche peuvent le
souhaitait notamment jean luc mélenchon
qui souhaitent par exemple augmenter le
salaire minimum pour qu'il atteigne 1400
euros net par mois ou encore yannick
jadot et fabien roussel qui propose
quelque chose de similaire le candidat
souhaite par ailleurs que les heures
supplémentaires rapporte davantage aux
salariés comment faire et bien on
supprimant les impôts et les cotisations
sociales sur ces heures supplémentaires
enfin pour redonner du pouvoir d'achat
eric zemmour souhaite mettre en place
une prime zéro charges c'est-à-dire en
fait la possibilité pour une entreprise
de verser une prime sans qu'il n'y ait
de cotisations à payer des deux côtés et
donc pour vous donner un exemple très
simple si une entreprise souhaite donner
100 euros 10 ans de prime à son salarié
est bien de l'entreprise des bourses 100
euros et c'est bien son euro qui vont
directement dans le compte en banque du
salarié cette prime pourra représenter
en l'occurrence jusqu'à trois mois de
salaire et donc donner éventuellement un
treizième quatorzième voir quinzième
mois aux salariés et elle sera versée
une fois par an maximum par l'employeur
7e proposition eric zemmour veut mettre
fin au collège unique donc le fait que
tous les élèves de france et les mêmes
enseignements au collège à la place
d'eric zemmour on veut en fait
réinstaurer des classes de niveau c'est
à dire des classes avec des bons élèves
d'un côté et d'autres classes avec des
élèves qui ont un niveau plus faible
l'objectif affiché avec ça c'est que les
meilleurs deviennent encore plus fort et
que les plus faibles progressent à leur
rythme par ailleurs en primaire
l'apprentissage des langues étrangères
sera supprimé pour augmenter les heures
de français et de mathématiques et on
pourrait noter aussi dans son programme
concernant l'école son souhait de
remettre la blouse à l'école primaire 8e
mesure eric zemmour est favorable à une
interdiction totale des signes religieux
dans l'espace public à l'exception je
cite des professionnels de la religion
ça veut donc dire notamment
l'interdiction du voile islamique
eric zemmour évoque la laïcité et le
devoir de discrétion dans l'espace
public pour justifier cette interdiction
dans l'espace public du voile plus
globalement exe moore considère que
l'islam n'est pas qu'une religion mais
aussi je cite une nation une loi est une
civilisation qui serait selon lui
incompatible avec la république
française neuvième mesure eric zemmour
souhaite renouveler et développer le
nucléaire à grande échelle en ouvrant 14
réacteurs upr en france d'ici 2050 alors
un noeud p r c'est un réacteur nucléaire
présentée parce qu'ils défendent comme
capable de produire davantage
d'électricité à partir de la même
quantité de combustible car réacteurs de
deuxième génération à noter au passage
que le candidat veut également interdire
la construction d'éoliennes sur terre et
en mer et ce pour trois principales
raisons avancées elle nuirait selon lui
à la santé des gens deuxième raison elle
pourrait détériorer la beauté des
paysages et enfin troisième raison elle
produirait une j'ai trop faible par
rapport au nucléaire qu'il juge
davantage fiable on termine avec la 10e
mesure l'interdiction de la procréation
médicalement assistée donc la pma dès
lors qu'il n'ya pas de pair la pma
permet en fait un couple qui ne le peut
pas et bien d'avoir un enfant grâce à
certaines techniques médicales depuis
septembre dernier la pma est accessible
à toutes les femmes zemmour veut donc
restreindre à la pma aux seuls couples
hétéros et donc interdire la pma sans
père dans le cas d'un couple de femmes
par exemple pour finir je vais juste
vous citer quelques autres mesures que
je vais pas avoir le temps d'expliquer
autrement en détaille eric zemmour
souhaite interdire aux parents de donner
un prénom étrangers à leurs enfants il
souhaite verser dix mille euros à chaque
famille pour toute nouvelle naissance et
ce à condition que cette famille vivent
en zone rurale temps supprimé le permis
à points ou encore faire rembourser par
les entreprises la moitié des frais de
carburant de leurs salariés pour leur
trajet domicile travail voilà donc pour
les mesures principales porté
aujourd'hui par eric zemmour comme je le
disais cette vidéo vient en complément
de l'interview d'eric zemmour qui
sortira dans les prochains jours et
c'est quelque chose que l'on fait avec
tous les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle du coup sûr mais ça vous
intéresse vous voulez découvrir le
programme et les interviews des
candidats rendez vous sur cette chaîne
youtube n'hésitez pas à vous abonner je
ne sais pas encore le cas pour ne pas
louper les prochaines interviews et les
prochaines vidéos enfin sur instagram
mon poste aussi les comparaisons entre
les programmes des candidats sur des
sujets majeurs du coup nous n'hésitez
pas à nous suivre aussi sur instagram
écoutez je crois que j'ai tout dis
prenez soin de vous pressons nos proches
et on se dit ah très vite